I want to see Italy through your cold
lifeless eyes so I decided to take you
to Italy that sounds great
so you're not rattled at all by this
we're gonna leave for Italy tonight I
can be ready in a couple hours
don't you have to tell your wife or
anything I'm all set you're not gonna
call your wife that's a quick
conversation
[Applause]
you didn't know what to do and so a
weird Joker smile came on your face and
then that's not no biological no
everybody what's going on welcome to the
live Q&A for Conan Italy yes you guys be
clap no one ever claps no one claps oh
we're here with associate producer
Jordan Lansky and of course Conan
O'Brien will be taking your questions
for the next hour YouTube Facebook
Twitter
how's it going everybody how's it going
and how how are you guys doing well two
things right away and I've said this a
lot but we're in a small room yes and
you're yelling I just get so much coffee
I'm so excited calm down okay they get
easy okay
and the other thing is I think Jordan
made a mistake he grew this beard he
started a couple of weeks ago and I
think it's a mistake and I just want to
get that out there and I know there's
gonna be a lot of comments on the beard
that's but you are now at your this is
your high peak your your acne your
apogee this is your greatest moment and
you've chosen to look like a sad Russian
poet is about to be executed
so I don't think that was a smart move
and I think you should shave the beard
let me see the beard is a vestigial
trait now evolutionarily speaking yes it
provided thermal insulation but it also
your these ones at Jordan so Jordan
Jordan we only have an hour let's get to
the first questions you have that's
right well so everybody ID the the Conan
Italy Show aired last night you can see
the full episode on Team Coco calm slash
Italy along with a ton of extras it's
the most extras I think we've ever shown
yes because we had so much we came back
about our specials worth yeah of total
[ __ ] yeah
it's an embarrassment of riches yeah and
I guess Conan could you just start by
you know explaining why we went to Italy
why this whole thinking about I started
a number of years ago hardcore fans know
this but a number of years ago almost
out of desperation I think it was it
started during the writers strike yeah I
started shooting some stuff with Jordan
and we had already had like a natural
chemistry around the office which is
real yeah authentic and then we shot
some stuff and then that inspired one of
our producers on the show Frank smiley
by the way who's been with me 25 years
now unbelievably they inspired Frank
smiley to want to shoot a segment where
Jordan takes me to an Italian restaurant
because Jordan so passionate about food
that remote was really fun and really
piqued people's interest and it started
the cult of Jordan and so for years
Jordan we featured him buying a very
expensive cappuccino machine five
hundred dollars actually
moderately-priced thing is you bought it
he bought it without my permission with
show funds this wall probably cost five
thousand dollars expenses on a
television show five hundred dollars is
nothing a wall you just can't go out and
buy crap and charge it to the show
that's not right and also you were the
only person that used it and you were
very finicky about letting other people
use it and that was my $500 anyway we
shot that as a remote and and this cult
of Jordan started to grow sadly and then
Jordan started babbling so much about
Italy that we had this thought let's
take Jordan to Italy and see this weird
monster in his natural habitat
let's see The Swamp Thing in the swamp
you know I mean let's see him let's take
Spock back to the planet Vulcan and and
so that's what we decided to do and I
loved it because of all the travel shows
we've done this one is just the purest
it's nonsense
it's a travelogue it's two idiots
ruining a beautiful old country there's
no point to it it's got nothing it's got
nothing to do with Trump or what's
happening in the world
if Trump saw it he wouldn't understand
it I just love that it has nothing to do
with anything yeah and it but I really
it just really makes me laugh this one
said rise you on Twitch a scone if you
could save only one thing or person
would you choose Jordan or your jacket
that's Wow this jacket is it is a
special jacket I don't know if people
know about this jacket yeah this jacket
I've had for a long time this jacket is
when I bought in a store years and years
and years ago
it's a beat-up old I think 1940s leather
motorcycle jacket which wouldn't give
you any protection at all
well then motorcycles went 11 miles an
hour I think but I bought it and then
I've worn it on a ton of remotes I wore
a Kevin Hart and ice cube ridiculed this
jackets along with everything else about
me in our ride-along remotes and so yeah
that's a really tough call a jacket
versus possibly a human life
you don't know if Jordans a life form
that's a tough one I'm gonna say Jordan
I'm going to say Jory because underneath
it all Jordan is a friend we've been
together through a lot of scrapes and as
you can see there's just there's a lot
of passion running sweetness right now
why do we even have you what did we just
have a cardboard cutout of you I have a
quick question for you yeah well he's
here who's doing the important job he
does you're at a show do nothing here
absolutely I'm still paying him anyway
um speaking of clothes Jordan I noticed
when we won on this trip you know we
were there for how long
maybe eight days nine days maybe I think
we shot six to seven days yeah and you
took it very you only had a very small
bag with you
howdy what's how do you pack what why
did you take such as you took very
little I felt like well I do like to
travel light both on vacations and in
life I feel that as human beings we
don't need much but I think that
sometimes yes I know that you only say
that if you're clarifying that we are
human because you're worried someone's
going to understand that you're really
from the planet Jordan anyway go ahead
you packed very light and I did surprise
you so we went that night yes yes that's
correct
that's true I have I travel so often I
have certain bags ready to go on a
moment's notice I have a toiletry bag
now I'm very particular about the
toiletries I bring and I use travel-size
bottles I'll never understand someone
checking a bag of luggage and having a
five ounce bottle of shampoo how much
shampoo are you gonna use on a trip I
only bring what I need one ounce at the
most you know what I don't use much
shampoo but I use up to 64 ounces of gel
and that's on a weekend trip Daniel Gil
and Facebook asks how many espressos can
Jordan drink in one sitting we did a
whole remote where you guys drank a lot
of coffee and Jordan are very particular
about espresso and coffee in general
also the espresso machine by the way
that Jordan bought for five hundred
dollars he's in a corner of the office
right outside of his door so no one else
really gets to use it but what is your
philosophy on coffee do you want to
enlighten people in terms of espresso we
only have a certain amount of time sure
yeah well you're implying that I might
take long to answer the question no yeah
well you know I don't know I don't know
what your answers gonna be and I'm sorry
that I assumed it would be long right
well if the word long one might assume
that the things I would be saying could
be interesting people may appreciate the
limit of the answer they may say that
your answer is too short can you please
expand on that
I won't to force them to ask twice can I
just add like a comedic note I don't
know if they're getting this or not but
we we must have Jordan on a single you
have to yeah because the whole joy of
experiencing Jordan yes is seeing his
cold dead eyes when he talks I'd go even
tighter I'd kill even tighter I would go
a little tight on Jordan later than you
would on most two minutes yeah there we
go that is what makes the Jordan comedy
pop seeing that there's nobody home
the lights are on there's Christmas
lights on the lawn there you go perfect
to answer your question oh boy I believe
in quality over quantity to me it's not
about how much can I drink it's how good
can those 25 milliliters taste what
milliliters of what I'm answering the
question directly I'm sorry you got lost
I got lost only recently directing
teaching digital there's like 19 year
olds here they just wanna move cam
around because they grew up on MTV and
I'm trying to teach them no this is how
Jordans funny lock in on those dead
sharkon that's how you get the gold you
had you had so many dinners with Jordan
yeah and I'm there one we put out an
extra yes it's out there we had one
dinner where we set it up and Jordan
told me basically to shut up because he
said you're now in my this is his
favorite restaurant in Cortona you told
me to be quiet and then you proceeded to
babble like a chimp on meth
for so long and that I actually told the
camera crew i signaled them to just lock
off the cameras leave they left and had
like a nine-course meal and then came
back you were clean shaving the
beginning of the meal and you had that
beard at the end it was a nightmare and
it bothered it was on Valentine's Day it
was on Valentine's that was on
Valentine's Day of quarter and you've
been to Cortona many times and you want
one thing about we you had the mayor you
got to meet the mayor was that your
first time meeting the mayor yes it was
yeah that was an honor whoa Wow and yeah
that's how it was just that was an honor
she was impressed by my knowledge of
Cortona which was very touching to me
see that is a full-circle relationship I
put out into the universe how much I
love that town
and then the universe came back to me
and said I've acknowledged that you love
our town I respect your knowledge of our
town that to me it was a true human bond
the universe didn't do I did I did that
the universe didn't magically suck you
into Cortona I paid for expensive
airline ticket flew you there
they recognized American star and then I
made you a big deal I trained cameras on
you I made all of that happen the
universe did Jack I understand to an
insecure person one might need to take
credit for every good thing that
regardless of who deserves you got it it
was a warm touching moment for me I'm
daring anywhere on the internet because
we went out there get into those eyes if
you can find life in those turn you want
to look right into that camera real
quick
you want me to participate sorry look
into the lens and what I'm trying to say
is that this is a challenge to the
billions of people out there in the
world if you see any evidence of what we
would call a soul a human existence what
Michelangelo might call the spark please
let us know because we're just confused
you can pull out a little bit now Muhsin
monsters will be on YouTube asked Jordan
who are your inspirations besides I mean
uh you know well are we talking about
now my inspirations with regard to Italy
Italian culture Italian art you just
said it's music I just said inspiration
okay well then I will choose to direct
the question as I see fit and we are
talking about Italy and I will talk
about my Italian influences and Andre
about Shelley but specifically his pop
music catalog not necessarily his opera
catalog to me has me captivated the
album's led Toscana where his pop music
it is his pop - albums popular but not
short for popular oh it's not
necessarily his opera clock for that
I'll go more with like a Luciano
Pavarotti he's from Modena where
mcinnis no is papa rat is Pavarotti he
doesn't know him he was a very good
friend of mine Bob Baratheon used to get
irritated when people said Pavarotti hmm
it's true we used to work out at the gym
here hmm all the time
Baba roopd you don't know how to say
basic Italian names hmm give me another
one people Andre abode Shelly Shelly its
buck Kelly the sea is hard
luckily heart and see it's a hard see
it's one of the few names and it's
Andrea baka Lee angry a broccoli all
right
babble away babbles may see some may see
this as a disrespect to Italian culture
but I am here to reassure everybody that
I am enamored with Italian culture and
have a deep respect for it
Conan Lawrence raised on Facebook ass
what's one surprising discovery that you
realize slash found out about Jordan
during your trip and did you go over
budget because of him on the trip well
we went over budget on food because
Jordan was in charge of ordering the
food that's right and he went for it and
kept ordering more and more of
everything and so every single meal
became this crazy feast it Giants things
of meat like neither yeah fasting since
we gotta get back to the Conan wait that
I would like to be at I was a bloated
monstrosity by the time we finished
Italy just because of the constant
eating you were ordering giant bowls of
pasta for breakfast which I thought was
strange I would say the most surprising
thing to me about this trip was Jordans
breaking up laughing I had never seen
Jordan laugh like that before and a
couple of times I think because we were
so tired we really do work hard on these
trips yes and we're constantly moving
and it looks like we're just having this
great vacation and in some sense we are
routing an adventure but it's very
constantly on the go yes and there's a
couple times where Jordan loses it he
loses it first in my office but then he
loses it
I think I'm around the train at one
point I don't know if that's an extra he
loses it a couple of times and his
eyebrows he laughs like a robot that
sort of been taught how to laugh by
another robot not even by a human and
you would laugh and your face would
become this insane gargoyle mask and
then he could he stop laughing and he'd
get really insulting and if I said
anything to him he'd say no you were
crazy I don't know that that laughs just
showed me to the bow
have other people been weird out by your
laughs well I laugh when something is
funny you don't laugh out of politeness
or a social obligation right like we're
sitting inside
he's like a giggle I'm like yeah that's
like a giggle bombs that you'd get in a
novelty store you just touch him and he
go he giggles like the Pillsbury Dough
Boy
but you yes you're laughs when something
is funny but forgive this revolutionary
idea and if the shape of my face while
I'm laughing disturbs you I apologize
for subjecting you to that I didn't say
it just it's just I've never seen
anybody you change so completely please
look up the episode where he's laughing
it's something's very wrong there it's
the laugh of a man who just hacked up
his family with a knife it's that kind
of laugh it's Jack Nicholson shining
laughs that's what I found disturbing
what would you say you did you learn or
realize anything about Conan during this
trip
Conan reinforced some of the things that
I've already known about him Conan does
appreciate some of the most primal
romantic things in life coming back to
the idea of a good meal we took one meal
outside of Florence upon my suggestion I
got our entire crew which was about 15
people into two vans to take a trip
outside of Florence up to a giant Hill
yeah and I said it would only be eight
minutes I think or six this is yeah this
caused some controversy you said we said
how far is this place Jordan and you
said it's eight minutes which is a very
precise time together
well someone tells you eight minutes
that usually means it's going to be
eight minutes
maybe nine maybe seven but you know
eight is very specific yes I think it
was closer to fifty minutes five zero
maybe closer to an hour to get up this
long winding Hill and find the precious
meatball we were looking for the food
was amazing the restaurant is called
that particular one was Perseus Fiesole
that was in the out on the outskirts of
Florence in an area called theism and
that was a very cool restaurant because
they had the food was amazing
the people were great we ate
family-style around a giant table there
were hundreds of us it was very
expensive I mean it wouldn't have been
expensive it was just the two of us but
you invited the whole crew and then gave
them my credit card and then on your way
out you bought everybody seven espresso
machines and then you tipped the
waitstaff ten thousand euros so anyway
it was a disaster financially for me but
it was a great meal
and what I loved about is they had
antique motorised Italian bicycles like
the early mopeds
but before mopeds I think they were from
the 40s and they had them as decoration
throughout the restaurant I love those
kind of old machines so I spent half the
meal looking at those yeah it was a
magical night if you know was that the
amount of transportation time necessary
I'm sorry that was your oh yeah every of
the meals why did you just go understand
I was so dismissive what you did was so
dismissive in the room yes it is very la
sitive statement I have accepted what
you said I am now moving on to new
subject material as you said we only
have one hour at a time here we've done
how many of these have we done lazy one
because you you know we're here to
celebrate the response has been
fantastic yeah I think the response has
been Korea number one turning video on
YouTube yeah and people seem to really
love the show I personally have heard
more about this show than any other show
we've ever done I called you last night
which I thought was a very human nice
thing to do yes but you talking about it
now it values it because it was a
special
now made unseen I called you and said
thank you for taking that trip with me
Jordan I think it's some of our finest
work yeah some of my finest working I'm
really proud of it and I thought that
was me reaching out the human way it was
up until now yeah but now I know why you
did it no but clearly I was suspicious
and took a while for you to come to the
phone when I called uh-huh because I
think you were in your hyperbaric
chamber I think your wife was like on
the phone fake beard on hello Conan
that's what I'm picturing happened when
we had our little fun what else is going
on there bingo I would say I mean did
you ever answer the question about what
you liked about code we host an opponent
appreciates the nuances of art and
culture okay uh what I I know that was
that compliment not sufficient for you
where you expect me something more than
that maybe something a little more
typical I'm sorry that I gave angle how
about thanks for making me a superstar
there's no superstar thanks for making
me the biggest star Italy has ever seen
you're bigger than Sophia Loren Healy
right now how about thank you for that
all right let's let's show you Tommy
also Lemony Snicket said that scared
genuinely scared me which one
Jordan stared genuinely scared all of
YouTube I think I'm sorry Jordan I just
I'm trying to read this yeah I'm not
interpreting I'm just listening
okay all right let's switch topics
what is your workout routine Evan
Schmitt on YouTube asks you keep in good
shape and you eat a lot of heavy foods
what's your workout routine yeah you
really a pig when you easy Evan Schmitt
I understand how the human body works
later camera how you look in the camera
I get a camera
what kind of combination of foods feeds
the body in a way
a that see I use inflections when I talk
I don't like to be directed it the the
vocalizations are really just I'm not
telling you what you're saying the brain
that's we don't want any Schmitz right
there look him in the eye can see me
just fine what I'm telling you is I
understand the human body I understand
how to feed it and I don't subscribe to
conventional wisdom on nutrition so why
don't you tell us what that is well
these were a long conversation we keep
on referring when you say I believe in
food combining at every meal I don't
believe you mentioned eating a big bowl
of pasta for breakfast I don't believe
anyone meals should be only
carbohydrates or only protein only fat
only fiber I believe those things should
be combined to mitigate the release of
sugar into the bloodstream and therefore
storage as fat these are complex
theories too much to describe in the
scope of this conversation but it will
tell you this
you're like a nurse that came to my
elementary school and lectured us on
nutrition you're now a nurse mrs. Hanlon
I think your neighborhood he came to the
Baldwin school and she lectured us on
nutrition do you have a problem with the
results are you questioning my results
maybe somebody wants information I've
provided that information and you have
to relate me to a nurse of yours that
you are clearly hung up about all these
years later I don't know what it was
about that nurse that stuck in your mind
for all these years and you decided to
bring her out now I'm trying to
communicate information to Evan Schmitt
all right Manon je pense Amita asked
what was your favorite moment in Italy
that was not recorded on camera I mean
we had the cameras go I don't it was all
recorded I think we couldn't go to the
bathroom I think they're gonna release I
think best slow is gonna be releasing
Admiral best slow retired Rihanna it's
gonna be releasing video of us
defecating in stalls
yeah I mean I think it's all I don't
know that there was an unrecorded moment
yeah of that trip we have so much
footage we can't we can't put it all out
yeah there's not enough room although we
did team koco.com / Italy there is a ton
of X there's a lot I'm just saying if
you think that's all there is that
right exactly there's tapes room in the
vault we could release for the next 20
years I don't answer to that question I
would like to volunteer okay okay yep
okay we went to Naples on this trip and
a lot of that was because I pushed to go
to Naples I feel like Naples doesn't get
enough attention I feel like it's a
beautiful city we had a great time there
it was tough to get there but we got
there yes upon arrival we decided to go
out to dinner we were in a van we were
staying in a part of town that I don't
really like and Conan had the sense to
say hey we've been sitting in this car a
long time let's get out and take a walk
and I said I know a great place to pull
over that's a five minute walk from the
pizzeria that we're going tonight we
pulled over in an area called the deku
Monte of Naples it's this beautiful
ancient area that looks like Gotham City
and we walked awestruck by the
opportunity that the night had in store
for us I think it was a magical moment
for all of us we walked through the
street I think you were shooting it on
your cell phone yep and I think the
energy was high and suddenly we realized
that the night was full of possibility
we were rejuvenated yeah that's very
that's memorable sounds remember we got
out of that car we took a walk what was
no Jordan we did your your trip we
basically followed rest and when was the
first time how long have you been going
to Italy and what was the first time you
discovered that this was where you like
to go I've been absolutely so many times
the first time I was there was 1999 1998
1999 and I've been to almost every
corner of Italy and every part of Italy
has something of value but I found that
the places that kept calling me back
over and over again that were the most
fulfilling to me spiritually if you will
romantically the places that I connected
with you wouldn't make eye contact with
I haven't yet but you looking at me
and this doesn't plate to me at all
you're a human being as am i no human
beings it's not reminding yourself which
planet you're on now which stage of the
eventual takeover you're in you know
what I mean just relax most people buy
it you're in Georgia slansky from London
we got it yes yes there are certain
places that over
over again were very satisfying to me
that became the framework for most of my
subsequent trips I see I see and would
you ever would you ever add a new place
from this dress from this trip the only
new place we went to was for me a little
bit disappointing it was not my decision
but of course I'm not here to complain
I'm only here to answer your question
okay
accurately alright what was the one
place is the coastal town of be at a Joe
it's a Tuscan town and the town itself
is beautiful but we went during the
carnival a celebration I am an introvert
I do not like large crowds of people
right we went to the largest gathering
of yes we did yes we did yes and I put
you up on a float that's when I made you
perform in Italian you I thought you
enjoyed that you didn't enjoy that see I
like a more intimate connection like now
we have us have right now yes there may
be thousands of people out there
watching but in this room it's just us
and that to me creates an intimacy right
I think that's the flaw we're having
right now but my point is yes it was fun
to go to that town I think of worthwhile
exposing you to lots and lots of people
and also there were a lot of Koreans yes
sitting there and they went crazy when
they saw me thousand so I love it when
I'm in another country doing a Travel
Show and I run into fans from a
different country who we did another
travel show that was a really fun coming
together yeah they kept asking about
Samuel the octopus is really cool that's
like can we just step back very quickly
Steve Gibbons on Facebook asked and
you've answered this before but just
maybe you could say it again where did
you find Jordan seriously what's his
story getting on Conan how it all came
about you said from the writers
all-organic yeah Jordan I think you were
initially you'll know this but you were
initially an intern yeah that predates
the question at hand but yes the writer
strike of no I think they wanted to know
that what you wanted - yes that was the
question Conan the questioning on the
show on air or getting on the staff
behind the scenes
you you started as an intern in what
year 1994 1994 that's the Year Beck's
loser came out coincidence or no then
then you got a job on the show we've
never understood what you do but you
were working here for a while and then
yes it was during a writer strike when
we didn't have writers we didn't have
performers we didn't have anything that
we literally just started using
hand-held cameras and shooting I think
you and I in the lobby in the hallways
of our flower center I think you were
teaching me to tango and you were
showing me your bullwhip and that's not
a euphemism
his real indiana jones bullwhip yeah so
that's how it all began
that's correct yeah I lean by peel on
you two bass notice Jordan is a sharp
dresser can you give us some fashion
tips do you maybe want to I think I
think Conan looks very nice do you maybe
want to give us the opinion of how you
feel Conan looks today
well Conan has one of the greatest
fashion qualities of all right now
contrast see the human eye is attracted
to contrast the human of the human right
other animals see things differently the
human eye is attracted to contrast the
lights and the darks the darkness and
the light much is our relationship
together one of contrast the darkness of
the light the your outfit itself right
now features that contrast you've got
your dark pants and you've got your
white shirt with kind of the blue tie to
add like a splash of something different
nothing too radical a blue itself is a
demure color in that context but you
have the I captivated thank you I
appreciate that I like to think I'm
general I'm a pretty good dresser this
is my overall look kind of hit biology
teacher that's what I'm going for at a
high school you know he's got the tie
but he then he puts on a leather jacket
to tell the kids he still knows what's
going on hashtag
you know Lil Wayne stuff out there
Michael Scott for us at Facebook asks
how many times says Jordan had to clean
his office you have gone into turns off
as many times on remotes I believe
you've had it it's been I think we made
you clean it one time we brought in a
professional cleaner and we really did
clean it up yes and within the week it
looked like there had been some kind of
bomb attempt it just looks awful so you
that's the one thing I have to say I
don't understand about you yeah you're
so fastidious about how you look how you
travel how you speak and your office is
insanity and it's just filled with junk
and I don't know and I don't know why
you live that way why do you live that
way I'm comfortable but is that some way
of you telling us please help me I'm I'm
so locked down that I need to be insane
in one part of my life please let me
just be a complete madman in this office
they see I am at peace you don't need to
construct my personality I am a very
peaceful man I'm very comfortable man I
don't have any hang-ups or insecurities
you have no hangups or insecurities
absolutely none you're the first person
to ever live on earth who is living in a
completely tranquil state I think Buddha
envies you
I do I think you're making these claims
that are Deepak Chopra has never reached
this level of calm that's what you're
claiming well I'm secure about my
strengths but I'm also secure about my
weakness
what are your weakness you understand
well I don't have a meet office so if
that's it or that countless murders you
committed just bodies littered across
the globe what about that you monster
you know nothing about that and they see
I'm at peace your peace yeah yeah sure
um Conan we're coming up with ideas
so you knew you're gonna take Jordan to
Italy yeah I was coming by the way for
those of you just tuning in I'm here
viewing Mandy Patinkin and good to have
you here dated love you in Princess
Bride of you fantastic
then you're great on Broadway and you're
aging very well you know he really hates
when I get in his shot he hates it hate
it good guy um what were what were some
of the things you knew you wanted to do
right off the bat when you were gonna
take cone Jordan to choke the life out
it I wanted to see the look in his eyes
when he knew it was over and that he was
moving on to the next plane I know I
knew getting a meal with Jordan was
gonna be key yes and walking around and
I just I mean it really is all you know
joking aside Jordan he's caught he's
this fountain of ridiculous statements
and I so I just knew that just walking
around with Jordan I would be constantly
tickled and irritated but then it would
be good comedy right I mean one of the
things that I think you can see in the
special is that wherever we went
Jordan would say now look look upon
these clouds these clouds they have a in
Florence the clouds but we mean the
clouds influence use like well they have
a certain quality to them a certain odor
and texture a certain like know these
clouds literally floated over from
Philadelphia it's the same cloud what
are you talking about and he you say the
most absurd
practically like touching any touches
stove and says things like goddess this
stone you can touch this stone and
you're suddenly mom and he's like
mind-melding with it it's like no you're
not but it's delightful at the same time
and irritating and maddening and I love
him then I want to kill him
it's a magical relationship Ameen up on
Facebook asks do you guys
hang out off-camera you guys ran into
each other on trips yes that's crazy I
was in Japan with my family exactly a
year ago in Tokyo yeah and I ran into
Jordan and so we started making remember
this little videos together and people I
think who saw them were like this can't
be a coincidence it was a complete
coincidence so even when I'm trying to
just be with my wife and two children I
end up bumping into you in a foreign
country and we ended up shooting little
mini remotes together yeah did you think
you followed me there didn't you no okay
in the sense that I traveled on a flight
that was one hour behind yours yes I
followed you did I intentionally go
because you were going no underlying
anything it measures on the internet
weird energy just weird energy whatever
that is that just must be that must be
on fire right now this feels great to me
I know this is how everything feels to
you this is how you feel when you're
sitting alone in a closet in the morning
with your cold custard pie this is how
everything feels to you under on
Facebook ass
it looks sometimes that Jordan is on a
spiritual path Jordan are you a
spiritual man I'm a very spiritual man I
feel connected to the universe around me
I understand that there is what we see
and there is what we don't see there is
what we can detect and there is what we
cannot detect there is an energy to the
room there is an energy to every point
within the room of course you're
connected to the universe you had to
travel through it to get here oh you
monster but you need there's points
connecting us all to everything what do
you mean you see we mock what we don't
understand now
man thirsty for knowledge would listen
to these things and say you know what
I'm not aware of that let me listen
maybe I can learn something but you
decide I found you long enough and I've
listened to enough of it and its people
babble are you it's it's emotional
packing peanuts it's just version it's
verbal non-protein mish-mosh that's what
it is
you're not connected to the chair and
the plant and the world in the universe
know you're here scamming me out of a
canvas I'm sorry you know Madeleine Sims
on Facebook guys Jordan when you feel
the happiest are you happy right now if
you feel I'm very happy right now I put
myself in situations that I know will
make me happy I don't run these things
to chance I manufacture my situation to
understand I am NOT passive I am
actively happy so for me I put myself in
situations that will make me happy
conducive to my happiness so if somebody
wanted to manufacture how would somebody
go about take us through it like what
there is not a better answer
everybody gets turned on by different
things what excites you what is your
passion what turns you on what do you
think about at night and then you
gravitate towards that I like I like
music with a large dynamic range to it
you know what I'm talking about is the
volume level difference between the
softest and the loudest parts of music
it excites the human ear so that's what
I seek out and when I'm listening to
music that has a large dynamic range
like an early CD mastering for example
from like the early 1980s preferably not
one with pre-emphasis which was very
similar to the Dolby technology that was
used some cassette tapes when I
encounter those situations it makes me
very fulfilled in very happy these are
the things that turn me on when I think
about what turns me on who turns me on
the things that turns cavemen on turn me
on the basic human primal instincts
Beauty art the love of a woman you see
these are the things that really speak
to me so I put myself in situations
where I will where I will encounter
these things and therefore I am happy
now can you say that was left to chance
but I'm lucky to be happy well there are
certain amount of luck involved but I
have manufactured my own situation right
just don't say anything let's just let
that sit you just saw
that's pretty intense breakdown just
pretty much live that was interesting
that was just an interesting moment it
would have been easy for me to do like a
comedic thing after that but I just want
to let that sit in its own sauce for a
bit like a dumpling you know oh you
talking about a vinegar sauce that you
dip in something into because the
dumpling doesn't actually sit and sauce
the dumpling is steamed by water cooked
by water okay okay it's just so weird in
here right now so weird well I'm sorry
if being out of the ordinary is
uncomfortable to you you see sometimes
we grow when we step outside of our
comfort zone so I'm very comfortable in
your situation you think that I'm a
centered calm person well I see you
giving me advice which might imply that
you have it all figured out that you are
qualified to give advice on spiritual
connectivity now are you at peace
because I'm very at peace you know are
you a tortured soul or are you a
peaceful what do you think well you're
coming to a peaceful soul and saying
you're doing it wrong here's how to do
it so I must assume there are other
people in the room with me
that was you just lost it this is like
one of those Manson interviews 70s on
prime-time television that was crazy
I have it you can't handle the truth
that was very that was intense
that's great that was fantastic I I
don't know I think I am a little bit of
a tortured soul I think that's pretty
clear sure I I think you would say that
yeah I am a little uh that's why I make
comedy probably it's a sad cry for help
that no one seems to answer my reward is
my reward a lifetime whew there you go
what do you do on that no what do you do
to center yourself when you're feeling
uncentered I remove myself from
disempowering situations and I place
myself in empowering situations there
are certain situations there so
this particular body language that I
have is empowering me right now if I sit
in an uncomfortable manner maybe I won't
have the the clarity of thought that I
have now because mind body and spirit
are all connected I just thought of
something that we should probably mark
it yes let me let us know if this is a
good idea but if we made a tape that you
could get like an app yeah they have
meditation apps and things like that yes
we made an app where Jordan just talks
to you non-stop and people used it when
they were having trouble sleeping
yes ample or calming down I think that
would be popular I think they'd be a lot
of people out there who would want to
hit that app and it's Jordan just
starting to talk and he just keeps
talking and he keeps talking and you
will have I think people would get a
kind of REM sleep they've never had
before
would you be willing to do that yes and
it's funny that you brought this up
because my favorite of all the Conan
Italy videos that are currently
circulating online is one that is a
bonus feature called
something for the effects of Jordans
long-winded tour of Italy and it is
probably eight or so minutes of you and
I walking around and me explaining to
you what I love about Italy and to me
that is that encapsulates my passion for
the country I think we should make this
I'm not yeah I'm kidding I think if we
made this well and made it available I
think that people would people would
really enjoy it and again as I said they
would get a real solid sleep a very
solid very solid REM sleep yeah
can you guys grant Lawson wants you guys
to say one good quality about the other
I mean we kind of did this but could you
baby say one what do you think about
Jordan a good thing about Jordan Jordan
is absolutely 100% true to himself I've
had you know he's a very often he is a
really authentic human being he's very
much true what you see is what you get
and he really does I mean you've
completely remade your life and there's
a there's an old American tradition of
people going out to the west
part of the of America and remaking
themselves right you know when they
changed their names and you know they
recreate who they are and they create a
new persona and I think you've built a
life for yourself that is fantastic you
work at a job where you do nothing I'm
sorry the various what are you doing
various duties various duties and you go
to Italy and you do things that you
enjoy and you have a lovely life and
you've come completely constructed it on
your own and it's very authentic to you
so I congratulate you
well thank you for that my answer is
very easy so much good to say about
Conan but I'll go the easy route and say
that he is the funniest man I have ever
known
Wow very nice that was very sweet not
sure you know means true ugly generous
if it's just true it's not meant to be
generous it is a sincere admiration
that's nice of you that's nice of you I
don't think you know a lot of people so
I wish I wish you knew more people you
know wish you had met all the late night
hosts and spent time with them and then
you said Conan's the funniest
then I'd be like yes that's right but
you didn't say that you said why do you
need to compare yourself to others to
validate yourself what I'm saying is
isn't it enough that you have made
someone left why do you need to assess
everyone else that's made people laugh
and determine how many times has that
person made people laugh and how many
times have I made people have you are
independently great you don't need to
could be compared to anyone this is not
a relative term I need to be the
greatest of all I need to be the
greatest and funniest of all superb
that's the only thing that's gonna cure
me of that childhood in Boston who cares
and YouTube says this Q&A is a complete
shambles in the best way possible yes I
mean we kind of knew going in this
wouldn't be so much a question and
answer is just power this is not
answering this is a hot map this is a
but but also a pure delight
yeah same time yeah you know Jordan
earlier brought up contrasts he brought
it up when he was talking about my
wardrobe I do think that what's on an
honest note what's fun and sort of
remarkable to me about this Italy show
and why it it stands out for me is that
Jordan and I have a chemistry that
fascinates people and I'll tell you when
I go out in the world people come up to
me in parking lots and and in-and-out
burger and wherever I am they want to
know what's the deal with with Jordan
and what's the deal with us and I think
what it's sort of fascinating about it
is that our relationship has a lot of
contrasts in it he does make me crazy he
does fascinate me I do really love the
guy I really like Jordan a lot we've
known each other a long time
and I liked and admired a lot of things
about Jordan but then he also I want to
kill him you know and I want to squeeze
the life out of him and then put him in
a shallow grave but at the same time I
wish him all the best and it's I know
that sounds crazy but all those things
are existing at the same time yes and I
think as you as Jordan will say the best
cuisines have the salty and the sweet
you know it's like when people put a
little salt in their ice cream you know
or a little bit of ketchup and their
lemonade this is stuff that people do to
enhance the different flavors yeah I
think that's what's fascinating about
our relationship is that it encompasses
the entire entire human and I do stress
human spectrum of emotions hate love
desire to kill desire to murder desire
dismasting too much of the negative also
desire to care for employ and be scammed
by so yes I have nothing to add okay Oh
Francisco a fury says I could watch this
for Vaughn chesco Francesco sir or is it
I don't know I can watch this for
another four hours we only have ten more
minutes if you're not close and now
Jordan literally because nothing here so
I have to go because sadly I have to go
make a show where I talk to some people
and
we do some stuff okay and we give it to
Turner and then Turner does something
with it but you are free to stay here
for hours and hours and hours and there
will be no noticeable difference in how
the Conan universe runs true or false
will there be any noticeable difference
in the response this video gets after
you leave its to me the more significant
question understand you're worried about
how it would do after I like what I'm
saying is usually you know my value to
your work day I'm saying let's if you're
gonna determine my value to work day
what is your value to this particular QA
if you left with this QA drop I think
people would continue to watch you yes
I'm happy to continue after you know I
don't know how the Internet's work right
that very clear I think we've reserved a
certain amount of time
yeah we're only gonna go for 10 more
minutes yeah and then it switches back
to pornography
it's just hardcore pornography after
we're off that's right and that's the
stuff people really want to see we are
the internet so the sorbet in between
various kinds of Germanic pornography
Jason Pollock on Facebook as Jordan you
have any tattoos and what tattoos would
you guys pick for each other I do not
have any tattoos i express myself
physically through other means
inflections body language of course
language you know I use what's available
training my hair my facial their body
hair and Joe genic hair that which comes
at puberty but in current in terms of
permanent tattoos no I do not
now I'm not aware of any that Conan has
and and I would not choose any for him I
would never be that presumptuous it's
this man's body he can treat it as he
sees fit we own very little in the world
we truly own very little I would like to
think we own our physical embodiments
our bodies the corpo in Italian of
course from the Latin
corpus where we get the English word
course that we done cut yes well you
think I'm Anna and my house follow that
no there's no answer I don't have a
tattoo
and I I know I wouldn't put it that too
on Jordans body I think on the planet
where he's from that's considered a
crime so no I wouldn't but I wouldn't
change anything about Jordan whatever
this whatever you are you're the perfect
version of it
mmm I just don't know what you are
mm-hmm but wow that was I was crazy I
literally do go into weird places when
you talk for a long time hmm I do I take
these crazy trips in my mind and then I
come back and you're still here hikaru
online on youtube ask Jordan have you
ever done a personality test
and what's your myers-briggs personality
ty n t he int P what in what does that
mean what is that well look the Cigna
most significant of the letters is the I
and you are an e I don't know what's
happening I don't know what that mean I
don't know what's happening well you are
a you are an extrovert now of course we
all have different degrees that these
are broad categories but predominantly
you are an extrovert
and I am an introvert that is our
contract you think you're an introvert I
am an int you why you made naked into
the streets of Florence nevertheless you
think you're an introvert oh I assure
you I am an introvert think implies that
I'm unsure in some sense I am certain I
am absolutely Shantou percent oh right
100 per 100 percent o percent this is
what the word percent means in English
and it's derivative however I am
assuring you I am an introvert and you
are an extrovert you are not an
introvert well whenever whenever we used
to on the old late night show
in your single days would show any
segment that involved you you would walk
through the audience afterwards and look
and scan the crowd in case a lady
happens my Jordans band you are not an
introvert gingka hnj forensic cornucopia
you are not that's for the Latin from
the root corncob to means to Giuseppe or
to Tudor oh these are the Nick to churro
or his brother John Tudor oh he's
getting close to laughing we get into
laughs the craziness but it's like a
Galati con queso al dente cibano Saban
no se siente oh he came so close came so
close to see me crazy face first into a
Rick this a Joker's smile if you will a
green skull well I won't I
laugh again when something makes me
laugh I'm not going to apologize for
laughing and I'm not going to apologize
we're not laughing you understand these
are natural reactions and their
biological they exist for a reason I
don't try to change the course of human
performance whose aegis is this is this
son what is this on son this is on
YouTube equation Facebook okay why our
YouTube is there anyone that runs
YouTube twitch in facebook who's
monitoring why should this be allowed to
exist
why don't we shut it down I don't know
yes Simon Stemmons on YouTube says oh
mercy this is like an epic therapy
session I think they're nailing it I
think they're nailing it i Conan and
Jordan this is Frank Vasquez on Facebook
says Jordan is there a day of the week
that reminds you of Conan do you think
Conan's more of a Friday or a Monday
well Conan's a read in terms of his aura
he's an Aries is a fire his birthday's
upcoming as his mind we're both Aries he
was born April 18th 1963
this 1983 he is also a John Kennedy fan
you'll you're well aware that that
assassination happened November 22nd
1963 the same year and part of me always
wonders is there any connection there it
was probably big news around the time is
that why you're so fascinated by the
Kennedys and
but nevertheless I was like five months
old I thought for a second you were
trying to link me to the crime redheaded
baby the scene scuttling away from
Dealey Plaza
that's what that's where it felt like
you were you were headed out there on
the grassy knoll what you saw smoke no I
saw a baby I saw a baby with orange hair
and a diaper snuggling away with a
liquor Carcano no madness madness I
don't know why you go on these flights
of fancy
the question was yeah so what day the we
would say of the week you get lost I'm
gonna remind you of well what day of the
week do you know I don't I don't I'm
gonna be honest and and I don't see Dave
the week I would say certain numbers
would remind me of Conan 18 for the
aforementioned
reason 63 for the same reason 6 for mrs.
heit these are significant numbers if
you're into numerology with regards to
this man but in terms of a day a week
out of the seven I'd say no they're all
to me yeah you're a Monday you're a
rainy Monday it's a rainy Monday and
it's the first Monday back in February
after a break and you didn't study for
that test and you know it's in an hour
and you're contemplating jumping out the
fourth floor window of your biology
class that's what you are now Monday is
the day of the Moon Luna D in Italian
right Luna moon - of course in Spanish
well we're talking about Italy I think
it's okay to celebrate the Italian like
the very answers were a variant can we
just have only Jordans eyes yeah only
Jordans eye oh my head
I only his eyes can you get even closer
yeah lean forward so that we see only
your eyes once again I'm asked to
participate in what I have to assume is
ridicule it's not ridicule this is a
science this is me trying as an
anthropologist this is me trying to
understand we might be a little out of
focus there there should be a way that
looks good
Oh with the rest of the time that we're
on this is just a few minutes yeah
Jordan keep doing that and and and don't
change when you speak don't look to me
or look to bleh
That's not me asking you that's me is
your employer your master so to speak or
their the your authority which to me
could be interpreted as a sign of
insecurity if I insecure yeah I exert my
authority on others now suddenly I have
security what do we have here again
close I have security in my authority if
nothing else it's something that we can
feel certain about that is your
certainty your certainty your comfort
you know that you are the boss in this
room so therefore you can rest easy see
I take comfort in logic because you
cannot argue with logic you can come at
me you know what I love organize your
eyebrows are so tired if you're talking
they're trying to leave you there they
keep trying to escape your head because
they can't listen
teamwork your whatever's coming up yet
they just keep this rolling for 24 hours
this should be on for 24 hours this is
the future of the internet right here
anything else you see on the internet is
a failed sad invitation it's a waste of
time this is where it's all going stop
the Zuckerberg testimony get
witness the future future of the
worldwide interconnected web or these
two dead eyes staring at all of us
knowing all yet knowing nothing go to to
google.com slash Italy for more jordan
and conan thank you all for watching
you see you guys next time